we already proposed a very comprehensive
and you know austerity oriented program
two weeks ago so we are ready to propose
again with some amendments and to make a
workable compromise in the beginning
when we propose that the creditor said
oh that's fine that's very good program
but then they change their mind and they
asked if they ask for things were not
workable and they were catastrophic they
won't continue the same austerity
policies that ended up in catastrophe
increased the five last year so I think
we there is a room for compromise and
also the part of mr. varoufakis and he
was sacrificed because he was used as a
pretext of the creditors no two to
proceed in an agreement so I think this
is also will facilitate things so what
was the point of the referendum then you
could have changed mr. varoufakis
earlier on if you're ready to agree
ready to agree to an austerity program
of some kind what was achieved apart
from the very strong backing for the
government's position by that referendum
no the proposal the last proposal which
was given to the Greek government as
they take it or leave it altamonte to
was not workable at all there was there
were points inside completely
unbelievable in the limits of
surrealistic for instance for all the
prices to pay taxes not for this year or
also but for the next year no company
english and i believe all over the world
can afford such a advance tax a cutter
the same you know regardless if it will
have profits or losses next year and
there were other things like that when
you three a vit in the Duelist sector
which is a circle is going very well
increase and this will will make it
completely not competitive competitive
with
other countries like from France to
Turkey so we are trying to to change
there but what we agreed to is they are
asking for a set amount of money so we
said okay we will give you this amount
of money but you know choosing our own
program they said no no you have to
implement our own program that was the
you know the point of this Accord and we
believe now that after the referendum we
can come a compromise